John Kukla author of a wilderness so
immense where's that title come from
part of its devoted based on a quote but
we kind of adapted it from from a
quotation in which people talk about the
immensity of the of the wilderness it's
actually a Federalist who was who was
appalled that the that the Democratic
Republicans under Jefferson had bought
the place he didn't he was he was
against it so I was kind of a fun part
of the the irony of using that in the in
the court age the place I should say is
the Louisiana Purchase and the destiny
of America which is the subtitle yes sir
when did we as a country by Louisiana we
bought it in by treaty in in April of
1803 what was it it was the Western
watershed of the Mississippi River and
the and what they called in the Isle of
Orleans which is basically the city of
New Orleans or now now Orleans Parish or
the city of New Orleans and so it's it's
basically something depending on how you
count him up thirteen states and little
parts of a couple of others so from but
you just drew a line from if you went
from if you went from from New Orleans
north to Minnesota and Canada and west
of the Rockies why did we buy it we
bought it because because it was offered
to us it was really that that vast
territory was really incidental to what
the United States really wanted which
was simply the city of New Orleans the
Port of New Orleans because the Port of
New Orleans controls the navigation of
the not only the Mississippi River but
also the Ohio River and at that point of
course the United States was was was all
east of the Mississippi River and the
the farmers and and merchants in
Kentucky and Tennessee were desperate to
have the use of the Ohio River to export
their crops what did we pay for it
we paid fifteen million dollars although
you say in your book by the time all the
interest is paid it was what about 47
yeah they financed it for 20 years at 6%
so by the time it gets by the time that
all the notes are paid off in in 1823
it's it's about 27 million and that's
where when you when you hear that it was
four cents an acre that's the that's the
figure that they're using for that
computation how big a deal was it then
it was an enormous steal Jefferson was
just flabbergasted when when the word
came back that they at the extent of the
piece of property that had been
purchased and and he wrote a number of
letters he got word roughly around the
3rd of July 1803 wrote a number of
letters and the responses from from
people that he wrote to are interesting
because the half a dozen of those of
those folks make the comparison that the
Louisiana Purchase is equal in
importance to the Declaration of
Independence and to the writing of the
Constitution why well but what it did is
it secured the it secured the Western
watershed of the of the Mississippi
River and the use of the Mississippi
River and in that way it put an end to
the regional tensions that that
basically could have split the country
at the peak of the Appalachian Mountains
because the Westerners desperately
needed to use the use the river and
there had been some separatist movements
in the 1780s in the in Kentucky and
Tennessee so it it secured it secured
that the use of that of that river and
then of course it also it also meant
that the the nation was going to be able
to expand considerably across the
continent to the Rockies without having
an a burr on that side of on the West
how many people lived inside the
territory at the time there were about
50,000 very relatively small population
now that that would be 50,000 Europeans
yeah it's relatively small in fact part
of the part of the pressure that the
Spanish had being exerted on them in the
in the decade before the Louisiana
Purchase is is one of population because
there's in them there's a significant
movement of people over the mountains
into Kentucky and Tennessee so if you
start immediately after the American
Revolution let's say 1785 there's
roughly 30,000 Americans who have gone
over the mountains into Kentucky in
Tennessee and there's roughly 30,000
French and Spanish inhabitants of
Louisiana by by 1800 the Louisiana it's
got about 50,000 but the numbers in
Kentucky and Tennessee route roughly 326
million this is at 3 to 26,000 I'm sorry
yeah so you know it's like the increase
in popular
like seven or eight fold at least these
sentences got my attention on page four
Thomas Jefferson and I'll take this
slowly never traveled west of the
Shenandoah Valley mmm-hmm robert
Livingston never got beyond the
Catskills mm-hmm
James Monroe never made it west of Erie
Pennsylvania
Napoleon Bonaparte never visited America
and his ministers knew only the Atlantic
coast and is one of his ministers
Francois is it barb a barber bar WA
mm-hmm once visited the Mohawk Valley
from his diplomatic post in New York
City during the last year's the American
Revolution and Charles Maurice of
Talleyrand
Wright sat out the reign of terror in
Philadelphia why did you put that in
there at that what were your point where
you're making the point that I was
making is it is that the story of this
diplomatic this diplomatic story is the
story of elite you know white leaders
making making decisions based on based
on information that they have to glean
from all kinds of sources but but that
they've never you know they never they
themselves never set foot in the in the
territories that were being affected by
their decision-making why should anyone
care about this and this 200th
anniversary
I think there's I think there's two
reasons the one that jumps to people's
mind is the is the land transaction you
know the size and and and clearly that's
that's phenomenally important in
American history because it because it
does reshape the continent of North
America when you think about it I was I
was working with it with a documentary
producer who was trying to reach reach
out to younger children and he wanted me
to speculate which is something
historians don't like to do what he
wanted me to speculate on what North
America would look like if there hadn't
been a Louisiana Purchase and and you
begin to if you play that game and it's
probably a legitimate game if you play
that game
Canada's boundaries would probably have
extended down from sort of Lake Erie to
st. Louis
there'd be a Spanish or a French
regime in charge of of New Orleans and
what's now Louisiana the state of
Louisiana state of Arkansas and so on
it's likely that yeah if the if the
government under the Constitution of the
thirteen original states if that if that
government had not been able to secure
the navigation of the Mississippi and
the Ohio rivers for the Kentuckians and
Tennesseans they probably would have
split off and there was a secessionist
movement in New England that probably
would have pulled it apart too and so we
would have had a you know we would had a
balkanized
kind of map of North America with all of
the attendant irritants and abrasion
that goes with that so there's that
there's that geographic response to the
significance and the other significance
is one that I think is is one that we
can now understand 200 years after the
event and that is the way in which to
indeed engage in in a broad caricature
the first 200 years of American history
from from Jamestown in 1607 to to the
Louisiana Purchase in 1803 created a
white male agrarian Protestant Civic
world on the East Coast
and at New Orleans in in in in 1803 that
world confronted French Spanish free
people of color which which was an
extraordinary shock to the American
understanding of race relations and so
on in an urban setting and and so I kind
of see that as a as a the beginning of
an encounter with diversity about two
hundred years ago and that that that did
counter with diversity through both
through immigration and through
expansion has characterized the you know
the the second 200 years of of American
history so I think for for those both
the geographical and the and the human
dimensions I think those are those are
the two ways in which I think it's it's
worth you know pausing to contemplate
the significance of this event how many
books have you written I've written a
number of books that have been you know
monographs for scholars this is the this
is the first time that I have written
book length with with the desire to
reach a general readership rather than
just a few you know a few my peers
where'd you get the idea the idea came
to me when I was in New Orleans I'd
spent almost 20 years in Virginia
studying Virginia
tree and working in in Virginia and and
I went and took a position in New
Orleans and I was completely bewildered
as to how that really you know
fascinating exotic and wonderful City
how its history related to the to the
the world of 18th century America that
I'd spent so much time trying to figure
out and eventually I think the you know
the the book is my answer to that to
that question that was puzzling me but
Arthur slicing our the jr. there in had
something to do with this you saying
your and yes yeah what what happened is
I I'd been in 1993 we played host I was
I was then director of the historic New
Orleans collection in the French Quarter
and we played host to the celebrations
of Jefferson's 250th birthday and it got
me to thinking about the fact that the
to 2003 was coming up and that that some
advance planning might mean that there
be civic and educational programs that
that could be put into place when
politicians realized that there was an
anniversary within their term of office
you know so so I began bright I brought
together some people from universities
and museums in the in in Louisiana to
begin thinking about this and I also
began looking for a good book to read
and when I in in in 1998 I think it was
I was found myself on a program sitting
next to fresh Schlesinger and and was
picking his brain because I had not
found the book that I wanted to read and
and I just I was I thought perhaps he
might know of something that I'd missed
and when I said that I hadn't found it
he couldn't come up with any more titles
than that and I said you know I've been
thinking of writing it and he just he
just focused in on he just looked me
right in the eyes and that would be a
good reason for you to write that book
so so how did you go about it I started
by that time I done a considerable
amount of reading and so so I simply
began it I as a writer I've always had
to I'd always had to write if I'm
writing an article I got to get the
first paragraph if I'm writing a short
piece you know I have to get the first
sentence I figured that given the way I
write what I needed to do was nail down
the first chapter and so I so I wrote
the first chapter about the same time
that I was working up the book proposal
that
you know for submission to publishers to
get the contract the one with the title
piece-by-piece yeah yeah that was that
was my initial initial initial initial
draft yeah he started it's been reworked
you know over the over the subsequent
months of course the skies over Paris
were cloudy on Wednesday January 25th
1786 and the early morning temperature
was 42 degrees in the courtyard of the
elegant new mansion on and on how long
did it take you to start that and why
started that way I wanted one of the
things that I it took quite a while to
figure out although somehow that the the
fact that Jefferson for 50 years of his
life took the temperature twice a day
and if you look at his commonplace books
he did this I mean I if I decided to do
you know exercises or something like
that for you know III might go a week
with some regularity but for 50 years of
his life six days out of seven he did
get the temperature in the morning and
it's like five days out of seven that on
average city that he got the temperature
written down in the afternoon and he was
just fascinated with weather and of
course that was the way it could work
and somehow that just that just spoke to
me about I don't know the disciplines it
was something that just was kind of
quirky and fascinating about him and and
then the other thing that I wanted to do
in that chapter was was try to try to
try to have a starting place for the
story and it seemed to me that that what
what happens that particular what I
focused on is two days in Jefferson's
life when he's ambassador to Paris
ambassador of France in Paris and in in
one of those letters so that he writes
he writes a series of letters that day
and then one of the letters he he writes
and he's basically surveying the state
of affairs in Europe so that was a
perfect mechanism to kind of take stock
of the situation of the world at the
beginning of my story but the other one
is their letter that he writes to a
protege really in Virginia in which he's
kind of speculating about the future of
the continent and particularly about the
fact that that many of these western
territories are in hands of the Spanish
and he any writes that that he hopes
that the Spanish can hold these
territories long enough for us to pluck
them
from them piece by piece so there it is
17 years ahead of the event if my math
is right and he's already he's already
contemplating in his mind the
inevitability of American acquisition of
what was then Spanish territory so that
seemed to be a good place to start as
you know when we learn about the
Louisiana Purchase right here but
Napoleon we always hear about France
owning it but you spend a lot of time
back and forth and back and forth Spain
to France and give us the quick history
on who owned that land sure Louisiana
was was founded about 1699 by the French
and was named for for king louis xiv and
then the in the at the end of the seven
years war or in American history the
French and Indian War the the French
gave it to the Spanish in order to keep
from having to surrender it to Britain
they'd essentially lost in North America
to Great Britain lost Canada for example
so the Spanish took possession and
administered Louisiana from the 1760s up
until just weeks weeks before the
Americans took possession of it in 1803
so that that Spanish domination of
Louisiana is is often is often missed
you know it's the you go you go visit
Louisiana for the longest time you ride
the streetcars down st. Charles Avenue
for the longest time when I first got to
Louisiana I figured that st. Charles
Avenue that was probably named for
Charlemagne well in fact it's named for
for Carlos the third who was the king of
King of Spain right at right on the eve
of the Louisiana Purchase that takes
into chapter 2 you start by saying in
the beginning the chapter Carlos the
third hunted nearly every afternoon from
one o'clock till dusk yeah roaming the
countryside in pursuit of wolves and
foxes that preyed on his subjects farms
and livestock why the hunting thing and
I guess didn't his son it was Carlos
Tafoya son yeah he Carlos the fourth was
the kind of guy who'd like to have have
the keepers run the deer past the Royal
stand and and blast at him whereas Karl
Carlos the third the father actually
enjoyed going out and
and tracking and hunting down wolves so
he was I think he was a real hunter
rather than just you know somebody but
but the but to get back to your question
the Carlos palace a third was an
amazingly able monarch and and I went to
the rain he he came to the throne in the
1750s Spain Drive Spain yeah and and he
died in 1788 so he you know he's there
and in charge of Louisiana at the time
when I'm starting the story calling the
Catholic King yes they that's that's the
the term that they used his his most
Catholic Majesty was the kind of formal
language that shows up in treaties
referring to the king of king of Spain
you say that his death though probably
led to the sale eventually of the
Louisiana Purchase I think well what
happens is yeah I think arguably Carlos
the third the father is one of the most
able monarchs and probably in all of
Spanish Spanish history and his son has
I think an equally strong claim to be
one of the most inept and so it it it
makes a you know it makes a big
difference that that you have a less
able man facing the challenges of the
French Revolution and ultimately of
Napoleon's when did Carlos 3 die
well you know I don't remember the exact
date he was he was forced into exile in
1808 I think he lived on into the 1820s
but I don't have the exact date in mind
when did his son take over that hit the
car I'm sorry Carlos the third died in
1788
and then his son took over in 79 yeah
yeah yeah and then the son eventually
get you know Napoleon kicks the ball of
the Bourbons off the off the Spanish
throne in 1808 and puts his brother on
the Spanish throne and sends these guys
into exile that stuff that isn't you
know I didn't I didn't I didn't follow
that that digression in the beginning of
your book you list the number of people
you thought were the principal
characters in this whole exchange one of
them was robert Livingston who was he
robert robert Livingston was a New York
politician who statesman and he was
Jefferson's minister to France
he'd been active in in in the Revolution
he was known in New York history as
Chancellor Livingston
separate to distinguish him from a whole
bunch of Robert Robert was a really
popular name in the Livingston family in
fact this guy's name was Robert Robert
Livingston but he had been he'd been
foreign minister for the Continental
Congress in in the in the American
Revolution and so was experienced in in
in diplomacy and alike and was
Jefferson's choice to to go represent
the United States to to France when
Jefferson came to the presidency you I
wrote this down you say robert
Livingston made the deal and James
Monroe saved it mm-hmm
Livingston had worked on the idea of
trying to get a hold of New Orleans he
had been working on that for months and
then late in the late in the game Monroe
arrives with with special authority to
to negotiate for those purposes Monroe I
don't think ever realized how much work
Livingston had done before his arrival
and so kind of had an inflated notion of
of what he had done because as far as
what Monroe saw he he arrived they went
through three weeks of negotiation they
ended up with a treaty and it looked
like you know it looked like that's when
it all happened but but as I as I think
I pretty well document in the book
Livingston had worked long and hard in
order to in order to create the
situation in which the treaty came about
the the the sentence that says that
Monroe saved it what happened is after
the treaty had been signed and sent back
to the United States for ratification
that summer
Napoleon began to have second thoughts
and it was at that point that Monroe who
had was even closer to Jefferson than
Livingston and had been with him more
recently and so on had the the
self-confidence to say we've been
authorized to spend two million dollars
let's give it to him and Livingston was
not sure that that was a good idea you
know you turn over two million dollars
to somebody who's about to back out of a
deal you know what happens when Monroe
insisted that this was the right thing
to do and and and only Monroe could have
done that because he was you know closer
to you can you could argue about whether
Monroe or Madison is it's closer to
Jefferson but you know he was
he was basically very very close
personally and politically to Jefferson
and so he had the the wherewithal to to
say let's let's do it and that did in
fact I think it did it quelled those
fears that Napoleon would try to back
out of the treaty do me a favor before
we lose you an entirely you your mic is
about to fall I'll just slide it back up
there and if up a little higher so we so
he can hear you okay sometimes they fall
sometimes they fall off in the middle of
this thing another name was Talleyrand
yeah Talleyrand is a fascinating
character in french history he said he
starts off as a bishop and then he he
leaves the church on the eve of the
French Revolution he's part of that
first early kind of aristocratic and
liberal or rather than extreme period of
the first years of the French Revolution
he's a major figure in writing the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and
citizen in fact it's interesting a Mary
Wollstonecraft when she writes about the
vindication of the rights of women
dedicates tally ran because he puts
women into the Declaration of Rights and
citizen and then and then he gets you
know gets afoul of the more extreme
elements in the in the revolution when
the reign of terror is about to start
and is able to escape under a diplomatic
mission to to England and then
ultimately comes and sits out the reign
of terror in in Philadelphia which he
liked about as well as WC Fields did he
didn't care for a little Delfy at all
but what happens then after after the
reign of terror is that the talleyrand
whose real forte is Foreign Relations
comes back and and gives two lectures
one at the French Institute they're very
very well received and published one of
the lectures advocates religious liberty
as a way of establishing this stable
government by simply trying to get the
the issue of religious dissension and
contention out of politics so he
advocates religious liberty and the
others he advocates colonies
as a way of rebuilding the French Empire
and also as a convenient place to send
you know Malkin tents and and
particularly what he's thinking about is
you know the pole Ian's got all of these
victorious soldiers who you know what
are you gonna do with him when peace
comes well of course as it turns out
Napoleon ever never has to worry about
peace but what talleyrand's thinking
about that and so he so he Bree
introduces the idea of colonization and
then that leads in turn to he and
Napoleon kind of get connected he
supports Napoleon and the cool that
brings Napoleon into office and Napoleon
makes him his foreign minister and and
you know Napoleon is one of his one of
his goals is to try to reestablish the
the French domination of Haiti which was
then Sante maying that the sugar colony
there which had had such an enormous
role in the French economy and so what
the Poli wants to do is is send an
expedition to conquer conquer sand amang
or modern Haiti put down the revolt of
the slaves there reinstitute slavery and
get that sugar economy working again and
talleyrand's
tolerance pretty much all for that and
and in fact this is what causes Napoleon
to be interested in Louisiana he wants
to use Louisiana as a place to supply
food and firewood and all kinds of you
know mundane commodities that aren't
very profitable that basically the idea
is that you don't want to you don't want
to waste slave labor and expensive land
in this you know tropical plantation
economy of Haiti which can be put to use
making you know making sugar
particularly but also coffee indigo and
chocolate
that stuff's profitable so the idea is
that you bring in bring in these other
mundane supplies from Louisiana so
that's that's that's Napoleon this is
kind of an imperial vision and and
that's why he presses the Spanish - to
cede Louisiana back to him and in 1800
do I remember you saying that that sugar
was like 20% of the gross national
product of France yeah it's something
like it's and it had a phenomenal role
in in in French overseas trade basically
what what happened is that they would
they would bring the sugar in from from
from sand Amman particularly but also I
think Martinique also had it and and the
British were frankly doing the same
thing at Barbados and and and Jamaica
but they would the French would bring it
in in and then process it and and market
it throughout Europe so it represented
something like sixty percent of the of
the foreign shipping that of the French
shipping trade it was a phenomenal
phenomenal important part of the French
economy let's go back to kind of the
dates and try to lay that groundwork
1803 was when the sign right okay right
when did it when did somebody start
planning to want to get the Louisiana
territory in this country in this
country well Livingstone was working on
that that idea early on but yeah this
would this would be 1800 living
Livingstone livers and when Livingstone
went to Jefferson is elected in 1808
Sophos in 1801 so when when Livingstone
goes to France in in 1801 part of what
he's interested in is is trying to
secure you know to you well I should say
actually actually say when when the
Americans learned that the that the
Spanish are ceding Louisiana back to the
French it's at that point that
Livingstone and the Americans start
working on the idea of we've you know we
can't let this happen so Thomas
Jefferson became president 1801 how
right see then he was let's see he was
born in 43 so he's was born in 1743 so
he's like 59 60 and he spent how many
years in France when he was he had been
there from 84 to 89 so you've been it's
been about five years five and a half
years okay then if you just step back a
little bit you have Great Britain at the
time in 1801 who was running Great
Britain then Georgia third and how big
how many people live there
boy I'm not sure what maybe 30 40
million I have no I would I would I
would guess France was run by France
with this at in 1801 France was was
being run by Napoleon it had it had gone
from from louis xvi and and who was
beheaded at the beginning of the
revolution it had gone through a whole
bunch of turmoils and different forms of
government and and Napoleon was First
Consul in in 1801 and then and of course
in a later on in the early in eighteen
four he crowns himself Emperor you say
he had an Constitution change then they
phone it up to votes yes I did yeah
apparently that's one of the things his
brothers did a great job of of
manufacturing these phenomenal victories
at the at the ballot box that in fact
were all frauds you have any idea how
many people live in France in 1801 no I
don't know Cuba was owned by what
country Cuba was owned by Spain in fact
the Cuba was kind of the base of their
administration of the of the Caribbean
area Florida Florida was owned by Spain
Canada Canada had had been owned by
France but as a result of this Seven
Years War the French and Indian War had
been transferred to Great Britain when
do you bring in general Wilkinson
Wilkinson shows up in the story in in
about 1785 he'd been involved in the in
various things in the Revolution he
fought in the revolution is originally
from Maryland and it started it started
off thinking he was going to be a
physician but he got interested and
became a soldier and and he goes to he
goes to out to Kentucky in 1785 and one
of the things that he tries to agitate
for is is is opening the river the
rivers periodically being closed it had
been open because the Spanish were
surreptitiously helping the Americans
during the revolution and then once the
revolution is over they they closed it
again so Wilkinson Wilkinson gets gets
all of these Kentucky farmers to donate
a whole several boatloads worth of stuff
and he and he floats it downstream
with the idea that that he's gonna open
the open the the Ohio Mississippi River
trade link and then when he gets down
there he starts negotiating with with
the governor of Louisiana with whether
his his scheme he portrays himself as
someone who can who was going to be able
to bring Kentucky out of the Union and
and and join it with with with the
Spanish administration in New Orleans
and therefore make it you know kind of a
defensive measure so he's he's sort of
playing both sides against against the
middle and what he what he what it seems
that he really wants is to is to develop
a trade monopoly where he would be the
only one who who had the authority to
bring Kentucky Goods down down the river
which we of course wouldn't you know
very very lucrative but he kind of plays
both sides against the river and the the
Spanish I don't think the Spanish really
after a while they don't believe that
that he's capable of bringing Kentucky
out of the Union but but he's his
information is useful and so they keep
him on the payroll you know you know
past the time the Louisiana Purchase
he's he's on the Spanish payroll his
secret number was he was nothing agent
number thirteen because that's the the
code that they used with Wilkinson so
he's quite a character somebody ought
somebody really ought to write a good
book about Wilkinson it's been thirty
years and the Spanish archives are now
available in a way that they weren't out
of Franco so have you thought yourself
that's that's I I can make it through
Spanish documents with a dictionary and
I can run them by friends who who could
make sure that the transcriptions are
good but but I'm not sure that I wanted
once you get into an archive and you
have to deal with both the handwriting
and the language I'm not sure that I
could master that one but the relation
and by the way you have some Canada in
your background yeah I went to I went to
graduate school the University of
Toronto and and did a minor in Canadian
history so I've you know kind of done in
graduate school I did American Canadian
and British history so I were you raised
originally from Wisconsin and where did
you go to Anna grant Carthage College in
Kenosha it's a small Lutheran related
liberal arts school
Lake Michigan and how did you get
interested in history I had a good
teacher
and that was uh Nelson Peter Ross the
late Nelson Peter Ross where he was at
that Carthage he he was you know he just
kind of turned me on to the discipline
and the other thing was I could never
decide as an undergraduate I couldn't
decide what I wanted it you know what I
wanted to major in and so I convinced
myself that if I majored in history
since that would be everything
everything under the Sun from yesterday
back I could put off you know put off
having to having to you know narrow my
focus and you know in some way in some
ways that's been true I've done a you
know had had a lot of fun looking into a
lot of interesting things what was it
town that you grew up in and Wisconsin
my parents were teachers so we moved
around a lot as dad went up to the ranks
but they're they're originally from
Milwaukee and they're living now in
Jefferson I spent most of high school in
town called Fort pushes up near Eau
Claire there is some reference in here
about you I think standing on the
Mississippi yes yeah what was that
yeah when when I was when I was a child
my folks when I was five I guess they
were teaching in a little town called
Verndale Minnesota north of Minneapolis
and one summer we went up north of
Verndale to to Lake Itasca I have no
real honest memories of Lake Itasca
which is the which is the headwaters of
the Mississippi River but I remember
seeing the photograph of myself and my
sister at Lake Itasca what I do have an
actual memory of his is up in Bemidji
they have these big big statues at a
park there of Paul Bunyan and babe the
Blue Ox that I remember you know that's
that's an actual memory rather than
rather than a the one that's been helped
along with a photograph so what did your
career I mean what have you done in your
life since then well after graduate
school I went to Virginia to work on
Virginia history and ended up editing a
magazine that was then published by the
Library of Virginia called Virginia
cavalcade and became the director of
research and publishing at the library
Virginia which I did from I guess well I
started with a library Virginia in 73
and
left in 1992 take a position of this
dark New Orleans collection so I spent
you know 17 17 years doing doing
Virginia history and library of
Virginia's were its enrichment it's it's
- it is - its - the seat of government
the equivalent of the Library of
Congress and the archives it's both it's
both the Library and Archives for the
Commonwealth of Virginia and what are
you doing now right now I'm the director
of the Patrick Henry Memorial Foundation
which is at Patrick Henry's last home
and in his burial place about 100 miles
south of Richmond called Red Hill
and what's that Foundation do today we
we basically have taken it upon
ourselves to be the kind of major
interpreter of you know of Patrick Henry
in the same way that the Mount Vernon
you know claims Washington and and both
preserves a site related to him or or
Monticello does the same thing for
Jefferson both both preserving a site
that's related to that man and also
trying to do educational programs and
the like that that simply you know are
there to inform people of what what he
stood for and what role he played in
history what kind of money do you spend
every year is in a foundation like that
Oh ours is ours is very small and the
comparison with with either Mount Vernon
or Monticello as as is one of a nap - a
giant believing we've we've got we've
got four four full-time people and I
think the budget is roughly about
twenty-five to fifty thousand a year
what kind of money do you have to raise
or what kind of ladies the foundation
have it and who gives - a Patrick Henry
foundation in today's we've got we've
got a lot of people who support Patrick
Henry for his involvement in the Bill of
Rights and we've got a lot of people who
support Patrick Henry because they see
him as a spokesperson for limited
government which you know both of those
things being being positions that he
that he held not only in his arguments
with with the King and and before the
Revolution but also but also in the
ratification are debates over over
whether
to ratify the Constitution so I think
those are the two things that are you
know what what kids remember in for
courses you know is give me liberty or
give me death
and Henry enters an interesting
interesting character because he was so
prominent in American mind in the 19th
century at a time when you know the
country still valued oratory as a not
only as a part of political debate but
also as entertainment and and and
because he was a man not a man of the
pen he's been kind of eclipsed by those
people who left voluminous writings by
the way the cover of your book whereas
this painting from of painting at leaves
in Cincinnati you know did it
Asher Durand I think what I must say
that the the folks at the at coffs art
department are the ones that that
located that particular painting in the
pursuit of this subject the subtitle
being the Louisiana Purchase and the
destiny of America where did you go
where did you travel where did you study
I hoped at one point Brian that I would
have to go to Madrid but I but I was
spared that ownerís trip by uh by
microfilm at at Tulane and and the
resources here at the library Congress
University of Virginia Library in
Charlottesville and Library of Virginia
and others so most of my most of my
travels were actually east of the
Mississippi into parts of the of the
territory that I had not previously
visited I just the the Kentucky and
Tennessee
and-and-and and Mississippi what's now
the state of Mississippi they figure you
know prominently and a lot of the
jostling that goes on it goes on in the
kind of the background to it and there
were just parts of that territory that I
was unfamiliar with and then there were
archives there that I had had not
occasion to use so in 1999 I took about
a seven-week research trip in which I
just wandered I had you know
some destinations in in in mind archives
in mind and collections that I wanted to
use but I also would would just you know
whenever I saw those brown signs that
mark local museums I stopped at those
sort of things and what I was trying to
do was to try to keep from making
mistakes I'm not sure that I mean
certainly I learned things but for
example I remember stopping in in
Chattanooga and I could I had never
quite figured out how Chattanooga fit in
would take because it's not part of the
early history Tennessee it doesn't get
treated when and you know I went so I
went in this local museum and the first
first panels in there have to do with
with the Cherokee dominance of that part
of it was like oh yeah you know until
until they were until Jackson kicked
them out that's where they were no
wonder it's not a place of you know of
extensive European settlement didn't say
D you know 1800 and so he was it was I
did a lot of that kind of traveling did
drove the at one time I thought that the
Natchez Trace would figure in the story
I'm not even sure that frankly gets
mentioned what is that that's that's the
road that runs from Nashville to Natchez
and or I guess we really should say from
Natchez to Nashville it's the road that
after the Louisiana Purchase it's the
road that was used by a lot of the
Tennessee and Kentucky farmers who would
float their goods down to market and
then dismantle the boat and sell the
lumber and then get to make their way up
to Natchez and then and then go either
by horse or by foot back to back up into
into the bluegrass country this sentence
and I know you noticed talking about me
when you read these books it's always
fun to read these kind of sentences this
remarkable document pairen which has
never been published or consulted by
American Historians parent confirms
Monroe's suspicions quote not finding a
better occasion is it guard Doki guard
Oki is authority who was he was the
Spanish ambassador to the United States
and the came in he arrived in 1785 so
he's there right before the writing work
Constitution okay quoting again not
finding a better occasion Gardocki wrote
I take advantage of the French mail to
tell you that we are in a critical time
never in Congress has there been a
controversy more combated than that of
our Mississippi mm-hmm where did you
find this and why is it why historians
not consulted it why is it never been
published it's it it and it's a it's a
that's a great story and thanks for
asking um there's a there's been a
contention what's the the background
here is that there the Monroe wrote
letters to actually to Patrick Henry
when it was then he happened to be
governor of Virginia at the time this
chamber in Rosedale
gave James Monroe was in Congress James
Monroe from Congress this is in 1785 and
1786 and he writes letters to Patrick
Henry reporting on for the congressional
delegation as to what was going on and
he describes what what's pacy you know
what's what seemed in is if his letters
at face value to be a movement on the
part of a bunch of particularly
Massachusetts but also a few Connecticut
congressmen to work with John Jay in
order to in order to get a Spanish
commercial treaty they were willing to
close the Mississippi River give up the
navigation the Mississippi River for 25
or 30 years the the Virginians were
adamantly opposed to this
why were they willing to give it up they
well from the point of view a mass of
Massachusetts they first of all I didn't
think it was important secondly they
they were not eager to have the lands to
the west become profitable because it
only meant that farmers from
Massachusetts might might believe or
that prospective factory workers might
go out or seamen and sailors might to us
so so the the idea of opening the West
was not anything that that folks in
Massachusetts or particularly John Jay
wrote on the number of cases this was
not something that he thought the
country was ready for and what was John
Jay died John Jay at this time was he
was the principal let's see he was it
was it foreign minister said a foreign
secretary he was he was the basic he was
the equivalent for the for the
congressional Congress before the for
Congress before
the adoption of the present Constitution
he was basically the equivalent of
Secretary of State and so he was the one
who was deputed to negotiate with the
Spanish ambassador and in this document
was again this doctor what happened
Brian is that is that there's there's
been this Henry letter so people knew of
it and most people dismiss this as just
being you know hyperbole that that
Monroe was just exaggerating because
because his contention frankly was that
that the that the New Englanders were
trying to close the river and push this
push the southerners out of the Union
well what what I found in a in in it
there's a big the authoritative big
biography of James Monroe there was a
footnote to a dissertation done in 1948
about Gardocki the the the Spanish
Minister so I got the dissertation on
interlibrary loan and and read through
the thing and at the bottom of one of
the pages there's a mention of this
letter that had something to do with
Gardocki meeting with New Englanders and
then in turn I was able from that I was
able to find a an inventory that had
been published in the 1940s and I and I
faxed a request to the archives in in
Seville and they sent me a photocopy of
the two letters that I wanted in which
in which this Spanish ambassador is
talking about his secret meetings with
with a Hunta from El Norte and this sort
of thing
and it was at that point that I you know
enlisted the assistance of good friends
who do Latin American history to make
sure that we got the translation right
you know but basically what what he was
doing in his dispatches the Spanish
ambassador and his dispatches back to
back to the authorities in in Spain was
confirming the fact that he was
consulting secretly with with some of
these New Englanders hey did you know
this is a very complicated story that
yeah absolutely yeah how did you keep
track how did I keep track all these
people all these you know what well you
know actually what star
in my in that road trip that I mentioned
is I would buy the you know those kind
of milk carton things that's used for
files well I bought two of those and
they fit in my trunk and actually by the
end of the trip I could fit three of
them in my trunk by the end of the book
I think I've got a dozen of them and
I've got them kind of arranged you know
there's there's a couple of them that
have to do with France and a couple of
them that have to do with Jefferson a
couple of them that so so basically I've
got the I've got the files and
essentially what I did the way I did
most of my research was was by whenever
possible photocopying things so I had it
to go back to in in the back of the book
you published some appendix or
appendices you have one is that proposed
amendments to the concert comes to
Constitution that's right it ever
happened to Wyatt yeah what what
happened is is Jefferson had scruples
about the constitutionality of the
Louisiana Purchase and the the thing
that most people jump to of course is
you know that there wasn't there wasn't
the authority to buy this big piece of
land
Jefferson wasn't terribly troubled about
the the the land the land deal and and
in what the language that he used to
describe the situation is that this was
beyond the Constitution
I mean his basically feeling basic
feeling was that you know had that had
the guys at Philadelphia thought that
anything like this could have happened
they would of course written it in and
and so on and he contemplated writing
writing on an amendment to the
Constitution to kind of sanction what
what had been done the trouble that that
he and others had was in bringing into
the Union all of these people who were
not accustomed to the democratic ways of
American society who didn't speak
English who had been you know who were
Catholics and and so on and that's
that's you know bringing those people
into the Union was what what trouble
Jefferson table and the Orlan the people
the people in Louisiana inhabitants of
Louisiana they had mixed marriages there
yeah they had they had it in fact they
had a substantial proportion of the
population of New Orleans who were free
people of color who were recognized as
having a role in society and Marilyn
white and married whites and like yeah I
mean they're Caribbean kind of paths one
of yourself things here is that this was
the beginning of budgets adverse
diversity yeah I think so yeah
by buying the Louisiana Purchase yeah it
kind of could it took this you know
white male Protestant nation and
suddenly you know it had had to deal
with the reality of people that in in
large numbers in one big event with
people who were who were very different
from what most Americans thought of as
you know I mean there's they're
certainly not they're there they're not
Boston former Puritans and they're not
Jefferson's yeoman farmers when did we
get Florida I know this is out of
context Florida we get we get Florida in
in the treaty negotiations of 1818 and
1819 which kind of tidy up all that it
takes that long to tidy up all the lines
of Louisiana Purchase we have that point
where I get at that point no so we
didn't have to pay Spain anything for
that I don't think so I don't think all
right another out of context question I
kept I kept thinking of a hotel bathroom
when you told us during the bathroom say
yeah you have the three Napoleon's
yeah now you know you got it's it's it's
a it's possible that that this is
greatly exaggerated and maybe even
apocryphal because it it shows up in one
of Napoleon's brothers memoirs published
you know after the fact and it's it's
pretty clear that he's you know
embellished it a little bit because
there's a point but but the story is
basically the the British were trying to
bribe Napoleon's brothers in order to
keep him from buying Louisiana because
they figured that would get him involved
in in the Caribbean and it would tie him
down and so on so at what point are we
and we're we're in 1802 early 1803 the
Spanish controller right now Spanish
they're still in control but it's well
known that Napoleon has signed a treaty
and is going to be taking possession and
so so what happens supposedly after well
after one of the performance at the
Opera these the the two brothers descend
on Napoleon finding bathing in in in
rose water and begin to it's Joseph and
Lucien Joseph and Lucien yeah Joseph is
the elder brother Aleutians a younger
and what are they doing what's their
there Joseph both of them are involved
in politics Lucien is is in the the
National Assembly and is the one who had
been been fixing the elections and
Joseph you know Joseph is is also
involved in politics although not quite
as not quite as actively I guess and the
idea is that they're they're gonna try
to convince Napoleon not to not to sell
Louisiana and particularly they were
they were fearful and in Lucien it takes
the lead here they were they were just
appalled that that that Bonaparte was
going to do this on his own without
consulting the legislature and you know
they they part of this is self-interest
they're concerned that he's going to get
himself in such trouble that you know
that the whole Bonaparte family gets
itself kicked out us out of out of
France and so on and so there's this
this argument that goes on and
eventually they're they're shouting at
one another and and and Bonaparte falls
back into the tub and Rose waters
splashed everywhere and one of the
valleys is supposed to you know he's
supposed to have fainted and after this
huge splash Lucien quotes something out
of some classical source of having to do
with with calming the Seas that's the
part that I think probably got got
dressed up afterwards when he was
writing it in his in his memoirs but
it's a it's a it's a it's a great it's a
great story and and what it what it what
it demonstrates is that is it at that
point in in the which is actually before
Monroe arrives in in Paris that that
Bonaparte was absolutely committed to
the idea of selling Louisiana so when
the dust settles on this story who in
your opinion made the biggest difference
I think I think Jefferson's handling of
this of you know whatever whatever you
want to say about any other parts of
Jefferson's career and there are other
brilliant parts and others that people
argue about but his handling of the
diplomacy of the of the Louisiana
Purchase is absolutely brilliant
it's just absolutely brilliant he's he
decides that he wants to bring about a
peaceful resolution of it he uses he
uses his his representatives both
Livingston and Monroe beautifully he
also uses Pierre Samuel DuPont it is a
kind of a back-channel messenger to to
the people around Napoleon he he just he
just he just plays this beautifully at
this time there are no cell phones there
Telegraph there's that's right thing
there's no mail takes how long it takes
roughly four weeks for a message to you
know you can pretty much count on a
message getting across the Atlantic in
four weeks sometimes longer it takes
three or four weeks for a message to get
from New Orleans to Washington you know
so yeah there's no roads there's no cell
so one of the what and in Jefferson I
think part of the part of the key here
Bryan is that Jefferson had been an
ambassador in he'd been in France trying
to represent his nation for five years
you know with these with these same
limitations on communication so what he
does when he appoints Livingston as he
takes Livingston to into his office and
they spend several days together going
over I guess we'd call them alternate
scenarios so that by the time Livingston
goes to France he knows Jefferson's mind
he knows how how he would react to this
that or the other thing when he gets a
chance to send Monroe he does the same
thing but brings Monroe to his office
they spend a week by the time those guys
get over there they know Jefferson's
mind they know what he wants they know
how he'd react because they've played
all these things out kind of in
speculation and so they and they've got
his full confidence and and they do a
magnificent job you know if it the other
thing is he doesn't he doesn't give him
carefully
you know detailed limiting written
instructions so that it's not like when
when the French say we'd like you to
sell you the whole territory they're
able to say okay the month in 1803 that
again at the
treaty was signed treaty was treaty was
negotiated in April and was it was dated
April thirtieth and the Senate had what
with it
Senate passed it in in in in three
readings because because because
Napoleon was said to be having second
thoughts Jefferson wanted to push
through what the house to the house the
house didn't have the court the house
doesn't have to ratify treaty I know but
yes subsequently what happened is when
when the legislation comes before
Congress for the governance of Louisiana
then there are very extensive debates
when when does Thomas Jefferson turn to
Meriwether Lewis and William Clark and
say I want you to go out there the work
the work on the preliminary work with
with Meriwether Lewis had started prior
to the Louisiana Purchase Jefferson had
brought in to Washington as his personal
secretary among other things and was and
then was working on that and in fact as
I do one of the chapters in the
background this is a story of of an
earlier precursor of the of the Lewis
and Clark expedition in in 1793 when
Jefferson wanted to engage a french
botanist named Andre misho in 1793 he
wanted to send him from st. Louis up the
up the Missouri River for for a variety
of reasons that that that didn't come
about but Jefferson used the same the
same instructions recycled the
instructions when he draw drafted the
instructions for Lewis and Clark all
right it's a little light than this yeah
but the George Rogers Clark William
Clark connection and George Rogers Clark
did what in all this George Rogers Clark
had been basically had conquered the
West for the United States during the
during the American Revolution and so he
was known as the kind of hero of the
West he'd held the Illinois Territory
against the British during the American
Revolution and then basically retired
from service he was he was the state of
Virginia never paid his beta's bills and
the poor man was was driven into the
poorhouse in bankruptcy by the by the
bean counters in Richmond but then but
then he he was being approached by the
French revolutionaries and so in the
1790s to with the idea that they might
lead an expedition down the Mississippi
River and take
New Orleans William Cox this other
Willie William parks his younger brother
and what was their relationship they get
along yeah they get along they got along
fine I mean there was the considerable
age difference between the two of them
but they got they got along splendidly
and as a matter of fact William used to
help his brother out when when because
because of all these deaths that that
that had been incurred George Rogers
Clark couldn't even accept land when
they when they when the government tried
to give him land because it would get
taken up by the creditors so William did
a lot of that for France again out of
context for France abolish slavery in
1794 years oh yes and when in fact did
that have on all this well it it had an
enormous impact on the debates over for
example over Haiti and Sandeman
and the the the the ideals of the French
Revolution
even before the actual abolition of
slavery fueled the aspirations of the of
the free people of color or the mulatto
group within within sand amang or Haiti
and led to the led to the beginnings of
the civil war that then became a slave
uprising and and of course that whole
that whole history of Sandom a and Haiti
is is an important it's an important
part of the story of Louisiana Purchase
in it's a much more important part of
American history than people recognized
at a time you have another book I'm I'm
thinking about it I'm kind of juggling
juggling two and haven't yet written the
the but yeah I've got another book in
the works but I'm not sure which subject
do you want to give us a hand I'm
thinking about writing about Thomas
Jefferson's relationship with women a
wilderness so immense is the title of
this book John Kukla is our guest and we
thank you very much thanks Bryan